well the first big cruise ship to set
sail from the u.s since the pandemic
began is on its way to mexico this
morning royal caribbean celebrity edge
left fort lauderdale florida saturday
filled to about
40 percent of capacity the company says
that 99 percent of those passengers who
are on board are vaccinated
janet chamblion is one of those
passengers on board enjoying the sea
breezes on this historic trip and there
she is
on deck janet good morning
tony good morning to you this sailing is
a major milestone and right now we are
coming to you from the gulf of mexico
the pandemic has slightly modified the
cruising experience
and with billions of dollars and tens of
thousands of job at sake
the cruise industry is hoping that
passengers will like what they see
cruising is back crew members and
passengers cheering this trip aboard the
celebrity edge
after some predicted the industry would
never recover
so excited yeah we're excited we're
happy to be here
definitely yeah yeah it's just nice
seeing everything like come back to
normal
chattanooga's swinford family jumped at
the chance to be among the first to sail
amid a return to pre-covered normalcy do
you have any fear going into this week
ahead
no not at all it's not a traditional
voyage only about 1200 passengers
edge normally holds more than double
that every adult
has had a shot the main reason we're
vaccinated to be here
the swinford kids and other children
aboard weren't vaccinated so covet tests
for them
were required the onboard experience is
different too
these over-the-top buffets that cruises
are known for
no longer self-serve thank you
cruises became covet hotbeds at the
pandemic start
carnival's diamond princess was stranded
almost a month after more than 700
became sick
nine died a celebrity cruise out of st
martin early this month had two positive
cases
even though everyone was vaccinated
aboard this ship
celebrity says vaccinated crew members
still mask up
and that they've increased cleaning and
updated ventilation
what would you say to americans who are
thinking
not worth risking my health i'd say
this is the place to come our objective
is to be
safer here than anywhere else on land
richard feyn is the ceo and chairman
of celebrities parent royal caribbean
group
a year ago at this time they were
predicting the death
of the cruz industry yes they were
and they and i think you've seen how
wrong they were
the three largest cruise companies have
lost 25 billion dollars since covid
the industry is optimistic returning to
the high seas
will eventually lead to big profits
as the swinfords enjoy their 12th cruise
eight-year-old will likely speaks for
many americans
vacationing this summer i'm just glad
that i'm
away from home mainly thanks
there are a lot of avid cruisers on this
voyage who wouldn't have missed it for
the world
and as you can see a lot of them have
joined us very early this morning
but the question going forward is this
what will demand look like
and will the cruise lines be able to
fill big ships like this
anthony janet chamblion at sea time to
go in the pool janet thank you